there's more classified documents
everybody has classified documents
classified documents were found at Mike
Pence's house I think it was actually
Mike Pence or one of his lawyers who
found them this after classified
documents were found at Biden's house
this after classified documents were
found at Trump's house I am
quite certain the last
political figure in the United States
to not have classified documents in my
house and I don't know maybe I do maybe
I I don't I don't know how I would have
gotten them but they're they're cropping
up everywhere including at Mike Pence's
house so what does this mean
it's eliciting
very very interesting responses
starts with Trump they find the
classified docs this is the end of the
world this is going to cause nuclear war
they sold sold State secrets we got a
raid Mar-A-Lago we got to send in the
Jack booted thugs knock down the
president's door oh we got to get those
docs this is a horrible now we got to
prosecute Trump
then they find documents at Biden's
office oh okay now it's not as big a
deal no it's fine
having classified documents no forget
about it and if Biden just did it once
it was at his office oh I was at his
house too hmm well I'm sure it was
really secure I was actually next to his
Corvette that is degenerate corrupt sun
was driving oh oh well and he didn't
even the president has a right to
declassify whatever he wants but Biden
took those docs when he's vice president
doesn't never right to do that okay all
right well yeah it's not a big deal
let's forget about talking about the
Trump thing for a while oh but Pence did
it okay good all right now it's a big
deal again
now it's a big deal because it's two
Republicans did it it's only one it's
only one Democrat it's a big deal
it's a really really big deal
and Trump responds to this and Trump has
had a little bit of a contentious
relationship with Mike Pence in recent
years because he wanted Mike Pence to
refuse to certify the election and he
attacked Mike Pence after Pence wouldn't
do that
but Trump says quote
Mike Pence is an innocent man he never
did anything knowingly dishonest in his
life leave him alone three exclamation
marks
huh
is and as with all Trump tweets and
comments and you think
is this ironic is it is he Earnest is
I I think it's earnest
he goes on he says they created this
documents mess for themselves by being
so totally deranged about me
and I did nothing wrong
so Trump's saying it's all about me
they're just trying to get me
stop going after pens come on the guy's
like the most honest guy in the world
now Pence after Trump's home was rated
in August Pence said I've not hesitated
to criticize the president when I think
he was wrong and clearly possessing
classified documents in an unprotected
area is not proper
so
now you've got Trump being especially
magnanimous
after pens with some Good Reason by the
way if I were pins I'd be probably
pretty miffed at Trump as well
but Pence doesn't defend Trump on the
classified documents Trump does defend
Pence to me this reads as sincere though
it is helpful to trump it shows that
Trump was right in the first place
about all this classified document's
nontroversy and it does something that I
think really will help Trump and will
help to increase his poll numbers which
is it makes Trump look much more loyal
loyal than other people in politics and
loyal than he previously had been and
this is a quality that people love about
Trump and it's it's not talked about
very much but Donald Trump
has been for a lot of his career
extremely loyal to the people that he is
close to and that started to break down
and the constant focus on the slights
against him especially in the last
couple of years I think has turned a lot
of people off and felt like a very
Turning Away of the focus
but
people really like this quality that
Trump will defend his guys and
ultimately that Trump will defend you
it's like that that Meme that he posted
during the campaign
Hillary says I'm with her he says I'm
with you it changes the subject and the
object of that slogan Trump says they're
not coming after me they're coming after
you I just happen to be in the way
that's that connection that Trump has
and I think this looks really really
good for him
the way that I know that I'm right about
how to interpret the Pence classified
documents nontroversy is that Joy Behar
on The View told me that I'm right right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the current
administration's New Year's goals are to
tax spend and turn a blind eye to
inflation if this is at odds with your
goals you're tired of the government
playing games with your savings and your
retirement plan then you need to get in
touch with the experts at Birch gold
today for over five thousand years gold
has withstood inflation geopolitical
turmoil stock market crashes now you can
own gold and attack sheltered retirement
account Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals text nulls kwles 298
9898 to claim your free info kit on gold
and then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with an A plus rating
With Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles Canada
be Les to 98 98 98 and protect yourself
with gold today that is Knowles Canon
wles to 98 98 98
today you can thank me later the way
that I know that I'm right about how to
interpret the Pence classified documents
nontroversy is that Joy Behar on The
View told me that I'm right
well the one thing about this that I
think is good
and it was just
and Trump I thought well maybe Merrick
Garland and the special prosecutor will
feel like it's politically motivated to
go after Trump now you know because you
got to watch the politics now they don't
have to worry about that because they've
got now they've got you know two misery
loves company well yeah it's not
politically there's more misery to come
now it's not politically motivated
that's the best part as she describes
the most cynical
opportunistic political motivation for a
prosecution oh I think this is great I'm
glad that that
uh Mike Pence had those documents this
is terrific
well hold on the argument for why you're
going to go after Trump on the
classified documents is that mishandling
classified documents is a very serious
very dangerous crime
right that's the only reason that you're
going to go after him on it
but then Biden did the same thing he
actually did a worse version of the same
thing and you let it go
then Mike Pence did the same thing and
now you're saying okay this is good we
can go after Trump again oh Graham's so
pleased but if the crime the alleged
crime itself were so serious
then you wouldn't be happy that it's
happening again if it really posed a
danger to National Security you'd say oh
my gosh three in a row we're gonna die
here man this is terrible I'm sure the
Chinese and the Saudis and the I don't
know whoever else
I'm sure they got this information this
is terrible no
no it's totally fake no one is actually
worried at all
about these classified documents sitting
in a closet somewhere
when anyone does it it's pure political
opportunism
Joy Behar has no respect for our
Democratic norms
are you know there are sacred Democratic
Norms that the libs always talk about
just says oh good okay two versus one
great let's go after Trump
the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it because
sometimes Mr Davies and the producers
over there they get very very upset
because they say I want you to talk
about this story I say I don't know I
don't want to talk about that story I
want Michael and you I want to hear you
talk about that Sam listen I got to
focus on important things I got to talk
about the sexy green Eminem okay I can't
I don't have time for it so they have
found a story that I've not gotten to
this week they they want my expert
opinion on it become a member right now
use code Knowles Canada wlas a checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
foreign
[Music]